hi guys today we kind of decided to do a
vlog halfway through the day because I
don't know we're having a day off on
Dartmoor which is a place by Plymouth
which is where this lovely girl is from
this is Amy by the way if you haven't
seen her in other such videos such as
the Pokemon go video or what are those
did we do
so come one go when is the funniest just
walks oh we did that one dot more as
well he did yeah let's
we're always we're always up here yeah
so we figured actually was Amy's ideas
they thank you Amy
Inc you lean statue to Vogue and we'll
show you up on the moors around
Christmastime yeah so it's gonna be an
attempt at vlogging today
yes
thank you
does it get
do you get funny of our holes no I'm
pretty good with hole
are you running away yeah real funny you
and bite you please don't fight us geese
be frightened tiny bit frightened that's
quite scary the hotel the clock yes
she's probably not focused
so pretty anyway I feel that's like
super scenic
on the health
welcome to Amy's house this is the
boudoir Amy and they all gave my boy in
the corner I'm vlogging yeah that's cool
this is Merry Christmas penis Christmas
Day Christmas D very messy and this is
where I sleep because I haven't made the
small bedroom yet I appreciate it thank
you
every time I get treated like a princess
and get bought back five cheese crumbs
five g's oh why is this always such a
big deal she's blogging oh because we
couldn't do the other videos we're still
gonna do the other video but also I
decided oh I said that we could Bob
because then it's like another thing
here multiple videos yeah also I got
five cheese stuff crafts and one of the
pizzas yes so that's a thing we got five
cheese stuffed crust
red Leicester Emmental EDA with no am i
making something I got a spicy veggie
and then we did do half and half so you
got oh look you've got a vegetable on
that you got just mozzarella just
mozzarella bit on me also got meat peas
yeah cuz I don't eat meat but you do eat
meat I mean there was this one time wait
you tell a story the pizzas we always
have pizza when I bring me up
she lives quite far away Amy M is the
best friend from young childhood school
school so we just feature that often
what we do it's good and we catch up and
we have pea
the video but one time he asked came
down and I was telling Jackson that she
was a vegetarian and the rest of this
pizza that was on our phone just grabbed
it making it good perfect and then I got
home and it had lived a pepperoni other
place completely forgot oh yeah my
friends are vegetarian protein pieces it
was cheap I was like it's all my pieces
I've got how Pinos onions peppers and
green chilies I'm cheese come on get to
a crust and see what it's like what they
say it's got cheese on top of the ground
P focusing across this is good
Hey suppose a friend I thought mom would
have thrown this guy away she hates him
though she's kept him for me
hello you might have noticed the change
of scenery I have now come back from
Amy's house and I am in my step for this
house because I am back home for
Christmas obviously but my mom actually
like travels around and my dad's super
busy businessman so I like to think of
myself as a nomad now it's great it I
actually realize how lucky I am to have
so many homes because those people think
you kind of just have one home but I
think a home is anywhere that you feel
comfortable enough to completely be
yourself to just sit in the corner edit
a video not have to make forced
conversation or or feel like you can't
make a glass of water and I am so lucky
to say that I have a wonderful friend
who always has the door open for me
always greets me with a smile and food
and coffee and wakes me up with
breakfast she is amazing and I am so so
grateful to have someone like that to
come back to when I come home to
Plymouth so thank you Amy I know you're
probably gonna be watching this it's
Christmas time so it's the time to
actually reflect and be more grateful I
know you should go if out all the way
through you the air I have got some
stuff to do I've got to work tomorrow
from home but I've just got some little
tweaks on a video before that happens
I'm gonna try and get a video out
tomorrow Amy and I was supposed to film
one tonight but I unfortunately became
extremely ill just after you saw us last
I don't know what happened just
sometimes these things happen and you
can't die don't know but I feel much
better now I think I just needed to
chill out for a bit then and yeah I love
being Amy's
it's so good cuz it's like one of the
only friends I feel completely chill
around and I can just watch her and
Jackson be freaking adorable and you I
didn't ever feel like a third wheel I'm
just grateful for their company you guys
everyone needs friends like you anyway
let's get them
okay so I am now exporting a video for
work which I have in the morning so I
can show them some stuff in work and my
laptop is getting really really old now
like it takes like half an hour to
export a four minute really simple video
so I think I'm gonna have to look for a
new video this is a really weird angle
but yeah I'm gonna have to look for a
new computer and I'm sure my see you'll
be happy to hear that I'm looking to go
for more burn a PC not a Mac and I'm
gonna keep this one so I've got
GarageBand and stuff um but yeah I just
need a need one for just for Premiere
Pro and After Effects After Effects
hardly even runs on this and if I'm
gonna use this for work it needs to be
reliable i waste so much time just
waiting for videos to export it's
horrible anyway rant over time for bed
finally thank you forming around today
sorry I didn't do it from the very start
of the day but you get kind of a good
idea now of what happens when I go home
and where friends are you can tell I'm
not comfortable right this isn't really
that comfy I hope you have a lovely day
or evening bye
no one hears any of this don't talk sit
up to the brainstorm but honestly